hello everyone and welcome to a
thrilling game from round six of the
meltwater champions chester finals it's
levon aaron versus youngshish of duda
and the game features something that
happens very rarely in chess even rarer
on the the absolute top level but it
happens nonetheless so without further
ado let's check it out and see uh what
i'm talking about so levon with the
white pieces opens with e4 uh we have e6
by duda going for the french defense d4
we have d5 knight to c3 and the bishop
to b4 now the winner variation of the
french with e5 advancing the pawn and
now c5 so this is all very very standard
stuff a3 challenging the bishop we have
a trade here captures captures and now
knight to e7 and while there are many
moves that the white could play here
like knight to f3 h4 uh even a4 uh queen
to g4 is still by far the uh the most
played move now so we're going after the
g7 pawn and black can choose to defend
it castling is perfectly fine here uh in
fact castling is the main move here in
the position and then you just invite in
uh white uh white white uh to
go after you for example you castle and
if something like bishop to h6 you don't
really have to worry about anything
because you have knight to f5 attacking
the bishop guardian g7 so it's perfectly
fine but after this we have queen to c7
and here duda opts for the so-called
poison pawn variation of the winner
french and offers the g7 pawn uh
leveling grabs it with queen captures
and g7 attacks the rook on h8 rook to g8
and now rook queen captures an h7 so
grabbing another pawn but now c captures
on d4 uh the rook is nicely protected by
the knight and we're threatening queen
captures in c3 to win material uh and
the game so here knight the e2 just
defending c3 uh and knight beat the c6
do that continuous development while
putting pressure on the e5 pawn
uh once again if you go after this uh
grab with queen captures an e5 right
away uh then you allow c captures on d4
bishop to f4 you just allow white to
develop
a lot of pieces uh you know
and you still have to finish your
development so instead knight b to c6
this has been proven uh to be the best
we have f4 now guarding e5 and only now
d captures on c3 we have queen back to
d3 now putting pressure on the c3 pawn
and d4 defending the c3 pawn but
sacrificing the d4 pawn uh so this frees
up the
uh d5 square for for the black knight
also if the if captures captures and
queen captures you can bring the knight
to f5 with an attack on the queen so it
definitely makes sense to bring to give
back some material to
further develop your pieces so here we
have knight captures this is by far the
the best move knight captures queen
captures and now bishop to d7 just
nicely continuing development uh and
here uh you could play a lot of things
uh you you can develop the bishop for
example the g2 pawn would hang so you
could play rook to g1 you could play
rook to b1 put pressure on this dag on
this file
but here we have queen to d6 offering a
queen trade and this has been played
only once uh where the queen trade was
uh accepted but here duda goes queen to
a5 he declines the trade and it is now
as of move 15 that we have a completely
new game so here uh levon again offers
the trade with queen to b4 and duda
again declines he plays queen to d5 and
now uh you can't really offer a queen
trade right away you could play some
like queen to c4 but then black would
very happily trade and then if bishop
captures uh we could capture the g2 pawn
so maybe not the greatest way of
offering a trade uh but you could
capture on c3 for example or just you
know continue development we look to g1
but here we have a4 by levon preparing
bishop to a3 to put some pressure along
this diagonal and now knight to f5 just
bringing a knight to an excellent square
and now you're very close to the white
king and it's not easy for whites to
make a move but moves like queen
captures on c3 uh
definitely come to mind but here levon
just continued like nothing was
happening he played bishop to a3 and
indeed he has insane pressure here if
the knight is somehow dislodged for
example bishop d3 characters queen to e7
will be checkmate uh but there's a
problem duda has a winning move here so
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for duda while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh congratulations to everyone who
found it i don't really think you needed
a couple of seconds for this one as it's
made in one so congratulations to
everyone who found it as everyone found
it and uh well just in case to those who
just want to enjoy the show it's queen
to d2 and this is now checkmate so uh
that's meet uh
in one uh levon had a had a playable
position okay black is definitely
somewhat better here but uh
still a move like bishop to a3 you guys
are wondering how could a player like
levon a former member of the 2800 club
miss such an idea
it's something that happens uh quite
often in chess when you take into
consideration the number of games that
are being played the daily online uh
it's uh up until three moves ago we had
a known position and both of course
arunyan and duda know this position very
well and these ideas a4 they exist in
they exist in pretty much every line of
the winner french uh just clearing your
a3 square for the bishop and it does
make sense black does not have a dark
square bishop of course you want to try
and exploit black's dark square
weaknesses and here
levon just had the impression that he
was still you know in the protected
waters of theory when in fact he wasn't
he just continued development he wanted
to play some like rook to d1 maybe put
more pressure on black's position but
it just happens that he blundered mate
in one and it happens we've seen it many
times um uh we often uh we often uh
mention that uh uh even chook versus
anand game or kramnik against the deep
fritz or karpov versus baref so
there's not a player that hasn't uh you
know done something like this uh you
know maybe not a mate but you know a
terrible blunder like this but it does
happen but i think what happened here
was just that you were protected by
theory at some point and then uh you you
didn't start uh using your head at the
right moment you you kind of thought you
were still protected but but you weren't
so that's what i think that happened
here if you guys have any other ideas uh
always uh please do share your uh
replies are more than welcome uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
levon most certainly didn't it's a tough
start but he still has three more games
to equalize so we'll see what happens uh
i would like to wish a happy birthday to
aleister fitzgerald and i would like to
thank andre frantischek balcovich
enterprises ben mcgrablin and aaron
anderson for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing uh with some more games from
this wonderful tournament checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world uh thank
you i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and i really
hope all of you found this positive
video moment see you soon